[Music]
just about that time clark county school
district students heading back to class
on monday
while many families are hoping to get
back to some kind of normalcy with
in-person classes
of course there will be some changes
kate houston breaks down the new grading
policy
and why some teachers say it's actually
lowering standards
this great change takes behaviors
completely
out of the question and it arguably at
the detriment of the student
tam lester a teacher at del sol academy
is preparing to use the new grading
guidelines
there's a lot of mixed thoughts the new
district-wide scale sets the lowest
grade at 50 percent
behaviors such as attendance
participation and late or missing
assignments
will not influence a grade during a back
to school kickoff
superintendent dr jesus jarrah says this
will create equity across the district
by having grades reflect knowledge
instead of non-academic factors or in
laughlin nevada or the core
of las vegas all children will have the
ability
to demonstrate however lester says this
new policy takes tools that incentivize
students
away from teachers and does not instill
accountability
what they will need is those
learner-ready behaviors things like
focus things like participation things
like time management
and some of these policies are taking
those away
the new guidelines were approved in
early july ccsd
is currently training teachers on how to
use the new grading scale ahead of the
school year
and it's not going to happen overnight
and i think it's going to be something
that students
parents and staff will acclimate to
lester worries it may be too big of a
shift
too soon and i know the district wants
to focus on intrinsic motivation and
that's beautiful but i think
we also need training with that you know
for the past history of education
is focused on classroom management not
classroom motivation kate houston 8 news
now